well the long-simmering conflict between
conservatives and Silicon Valley is
increasingly lurching into an all-out
war just last week James d'amour suit
Google for firing him over an internal
memo on diversity that was basically
unremarkable by normal people standards
now conservative journalist Chuck
Johnson has sued Twitter after it banned
his account mildly innopolis and Roger
stone threatened to do the same thing
new videos meanwhile from Project
Veritas suggest that Twitter
deliberately shadow banned certain users
likely for politically motivated reasons
Twitter when we asked him didn't really
deny it
author and columnist mark Stein joins us
tonight to assess the wreckage of
Silicon Valley and we learned mark that
a lot of these companies suck up to the
repressive authoritarian government of
China and squelch speech for the sake of
increasing their profit margins is there
any moral authority left in Silicon
Valley
I don't think so China is the last big
market to conquer it doesn't really make
a lot of difference in money terms but
down the road they they see it as that
and and if you look at it in particular
the Internet has in the last 10 years I
love the Internet I preferred the
internet 10 15 years ago in the last
decade it's dwindled down to a duopoly
basically Facebook and Google who
between them take 84% of the digital
revenue on the entire planet excluding
China and that actually means that
Google and Facebook account for over 30%
of all revenue on the planet
so they're basically beyond market
pressures and they have a highly
ideological politicized staff who as we
saw in these leaks from Twitter
basically are glorying reveling in the
power they have to do down their
ideological foes
so I don't understand a really simple
question since I live in Washington here
you have two companies at least two that
are operating what is textbook monopoly
to the detriment of consumers in this
country they're really a threat
to the US government that they're and
they're more powerful newest government
and the US Congress which is charged
overseeing this and preventing this from
happening throws up his hands and says I
don't see any violation here I I don't
understand how they could sit infinitely
in the face of this threat no well I
thought senator Lee was rather
unimpressive on your show a couple of
days ago on this Tucker very
disappointing in a sense we are in a
very potentially dangerous situation
here because as you say this is a de
facto Google Facebook monopoly around
the planet and if you look at for
example the European Union Angela Merkel
actually wants Facebook she's caught on
tape with Zuckerberg in effect asking
Zuckerberg to control and enforce the
restriction of sort of right-wing
populist movements in in Germany Theresa
May in Britain looks on Facebook and
Twitter for the in the same way that she
wants them to be higher end forces and
so I think the danger here is that in
America in the European Union and
elsewhere in a sense the natural
political inclinations of Facebook and
Google are incentivized by craven
politicians there's a kind of logic if
you want to steer clear there be on
commercial pressure now only antitrust
pressure in the in Washington or in
Brussels could restrain this entity but
but in a sense they found a political
sweet spot that incentivizes left the
left-wing thought control they're
engaging in and yet Republicans control
almost all levers of power in the US
government and they're doing nothing
maybe I'm right later in the week you
can come back on and tell me what the
point of voting for them in the first
place was I did that that may be a very
long and depressing might be mark Stein
thank you as always
the ratings Bob to boot thank you